[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
9% au mois d'août 2000 21 par rapport à
août 2020 on n'avait pas vu une
inflation pareil depuis trois ans et si
l'on comparé à juillet de cette année
l'augmentation atteint 0,6 pour cent
autant dire beaucoup mais faut-il pour
autant s'en inquiéter pour tenter de
répondre à cette question il faut
d'abord comprendre comment l'inflation
est mesuré chaque mois le chiffre de
l'inflation est mesurée par l'insee vial
l'évolution de son indice des prix à la
consommation
l'insee relève quelques 160 pays pris
dans trente mille points de vente 500
milles sont collectées sur internet et
depuis 2020 80 millions sont suivis
grâce aux tickets de caisse des magasins
l'insee tend ainsi de représenter une
sorte de panier fixe de dépenses mais ne
prend que très peu en compte certaines
données notamment le prix de
l'immobilier selon l' indice des prix à
la consommation ils ne représenteraient
que
6,1 pour cent des dépenses inutile de
dire que le chiffre est largement
sous-évalué et fausse un peu la véracité
de l' indice pour ne va pas être
médisant sur les prix de l'alimentation
de l'énergie du tabac ou des services
l'augmentation est bel et bien là et
elle s'explique surtout par la flambée
des prix du pétrole et des matières
premières avec l'industrie qui redémarre
la demande à boudy et l'offre n'a pas
réussi à suivre par ricochet ce sont
donc les consommateurs qui payent la
note et pas qu'en france dans le monde
entier
reste à savoir si cela va durer une fois
que l'offre aura réussi à s'aligner sur
la demande du côté des banques centrales
chargé des politiques monétaires on est
plutôt confiant et on garantit que cette
inflation n'est que temporaire